we spend a lot of time on the show
talking about ideology what people
believe but in the end the measure of a
government is not its ideas
it's the effects of its policies on you
can you
walk around the mall without getting
mugged can you
send your kids to school with the hope
that they will be educated
can you run your air conditioning in the
summer without worrying there's going to
be a brown out because the electrical
grid has been so
degraded by bad policies those are the
things
can you take a southwest airlines flight
to go see your family
when those things start to become
impossible you know you've got bad
government well over the weekend a lot
of american air travelers found out
things are falling apart southwest
airlines canceled probably half their
flights this weekend now why did that
happen
well we told you last night the truth
about why it happened we know the truth
because we've spoken to people who are
directly involved in it
pilots at southwest airlines are facing
a vaccine mandate they will be fired
right before christmas if they don't
submit to medicine they don't want to
take a lot of them have already
recovered from covet they don't need the
vaccines but the by administration is
forcing them anyway
and so this weekend a lot of them didn't
show up for work that used to be called
civil disobedience but that's what's
actually happening that happened this
weekend there's no doubt about it
and the fact that virtually everyone in
charge is lying about it tells you a lot
it tells you in the one hand they don't
want to own up to the results of their
policies their reckless crazy policies
which are an effective power grab and
not public health but it also tells you
they're very worried
because when ordinary people realize
they have power too especially people
with skills people who do things most
people can't do like fly airplanes or
run air traffic control centers when
they realize simply by not doing those
things they can be heard
maybe the government has less power than
they think they do
so for the past 24 hours you've seen the
usual liar stand up and shout us down oh
no that's not what happened it was
weather that somehow only affected
southwest airlines
you heard the ceo of southwest airlines
go on television and tell that lie
his name is gary kelly he's under an
awful lot of pressure
so maybe he had to lie but he definitely
lied he went on tv today and said oh no
it had nothing to do with biden's
vaccine mandates watch
seems a lot of people invested in this
idea that this is somehow related to
vaccine mandates
there's just no evidence of that you
know as i said and as captain murray
said our people are working very hard
they're doing a great job i'm very proud
of them
and especially when we get into a
difficult situation like this
they're also delayed they're also ending
up in places
that they didn't expect so
now our people are doing a phenomenal
job
where people are doing a phenomenal job
standing up for what they believe in the
face of tyranny
but to say there's no evidence this was
the result a direct reaction to joe
biden vaccine mandates is a lie and you
know it's a lie if you know anything
about the company you run and does he
does
later in the same interview gary kelly
of southwest made it clear that biden's
mandate is the only reason he's forcing
his employees to get the shot or be
fired
and the vaccine mandate obviously is
controversial and it's not anything that
that i wish for our company this is a
government mandate it's a presidential
order
and we're doing our best to comply with
that
oh it's a government mandate that would
be the same government that is ignoring
its own laws that is ignoring federal
immigration law and allowing the rest of
the world into our country unchecked
that's a violation of the law the bide
administration is abetting illegal
behavior so for the ceo of a company say
we must follow the law
as directed by an administration that is
violating the law on a mass scale
is a little much and everyone knows it
lying
lying lying
well the governor of texas to his great
credit greg abbott just banned vaccine
mandates in his state southwest is
headquartered in texas and yet southwest
and now american airlines and ibm have
announced they will defy greg abbott's
ban
oh they're more afraid of joe biden they
are of greg abbott let's hope that
changes
over at the white house by the way joe
biden's top flak was doing what she does
every day lying lying lying hear more
lies about what happened at southwest
i know there was a little
hubbub over the course of the last few
days about
southwest airlines we now know that some
of those claims were absolutely false
and actually the issues were
completely unrelated to vaccine mandates
oh you lie
they were not completely unrelated to
vaccine mandates talk to the people who
called in sick they were a direct result
of the vaccine mandates you did this joe
biden white house you are wrecking
our interstate travel system and over
christmas you're gonna make it
impossible for people to travel you did
that and at some point it's gonna be
very obvious to the whole country
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else